For that, you'll need a more complex storage
system like WebSQL or IndexDB. WebSQL provides a SQL
light based database directly in the browser. You can
use SQL queries to access data and to find
relationships. And ,you can have structured data in
your value storage as well. Now, this is significantly
more complex. Than the simple and limited key value
storage and local store. However, there's two main problems
with it. The first problem is, although this
API is available in Chrome, Safari, and Opera
and IOS Safari in the Android browser, even,
it's not available on IE or Firefox. The
second problem is clear from the specification, which
is no longer being maintained. In short, web
SQL is a dead end. It's out there
in Chrome, the Android browsers, Safari and IOS
Safari, and Opera. But, it's not available in IE
or Firefox ,and it's likely that it never will be.